[Alkış]
sizi görmüyorum ama iyi bir şey bu
aslında daha iyi
şöyle bir şey düşünüyorum Bugün burası
yani çok değerli konuşmacıları
ağırladı bu
demekten yükselmekten bahsettiler ben
size
iniş mutluluğumla söz edeceğim bahsed
eceğim 1800'lerde yaşamış çok sevdiğim
Fransız bir şairi var meşhur kötülük
hissetmenin yazarı onun benim çok sık
referans verdiğim şöyle bir cümlesi var
her insanda sürekli iki Arzu vardır Biri
tarihe doğru öteki şeytana doğru
Tanrı'ya sığınmış bir yükselme isteğidir
şeytanın Yakut hayvanlıyım ki ise bir
iniş mutluluğudur
Roman bir yazar var Emir çoğan diye O da
uçurum kusursuzluğu diye bir tabir
kullanıyor şu cümlesinde
nasıl bir uçurum kusursuzluğuna
ulaşmışım ki düşecek yerim bile kalmamış
onun ibadet bir cümleden söyleyeceğim Bu
sefer Yunan yazar zorba'nın yazarı Nikos
kazansa herkes mezar taşında şu yazıyor
işte şey umuyorum hiçbir şeyden
korkmuyorum özgürüm
şimdi bu cümlelerin şu yüzden söyledim
okudum
kulağa olumsuz tınlasa da bence çok
olumlu bir şeye
belki pozitif neizm diye
adlandırabileceğimiz bir sürece bir
akışa işaret ettiğini düşünüyorum
çünkü
biraz da tabii
absürdüğümde karışık spor felsefesi var
yani
bunu böyle çok yavaş yavaş ufak ufak
anlatmayı deneyeceğim bu sefer
direksiyonu başka bir yazara kıracağım
dosyaya geçmek istiyorum böyle onun
üstünden deneyeceğim anlatmaya
dosya eskiye dair en sevdiğim şeylerden
biri mesela Herkes bir başkasının
suçluyordu freud'a göre her şeyim
sorumlusu annesiyle
[Müzik]
bozmuştu kafayı şoförler kadınlardı
bir başkasının suçlamıyordu kendini
suçluyordu yani Zaten delikanlı
kitabında da böyle bir cümlesi var suçlu
olmaya bayılırım
özellikle kendime karşı
şimdi bu Niye hoşuma gidiyor çünkü
kendine karşı acımasızca Dürüst olan
biri bir yandan da aslında bayağı böyle
Sorumluluk sahibi bir insandır yani
eylemleri üstünde Elbette başkalarının
birçok etkisi olduğunu bilir ama en
nihayetinde bunun butonların kendisi ile
alakalı olduğunu da bilir bu da tabi
biraz varoluşçu kafası onlar da işte
insanın kendi kendini inşa ettiğini
söylüyorlar
ama dosyayı eskideki inşa hali bana öyle
geliyor ki yıkımla ilgili yıkımdan
kastım yine bu işte mutluluğu çünkü yani
Adamın eylemlerine baktığımızda
üç şey görüyorum ben
suç
pişmanlık ve bağışlanma isteyence Ama
tabii ki bir yandan da hayatta böyle
büyük
tür Hani
günlüklerine bakıyoruz kumar düşkünü bir
adam ama keyifler oluyor Bayağı da zayıf
oluyor yani yazmış bunu ve sürekli
oynuyor kaybediyor bir daha yapmayacağım
diyor falan ama devam ediyor Yani işte
bu
bizim bu duyguyu anlamamız için Kumarbaz
olmamız gerekmiyor
Sonuçta Mesela yani hangi
suç ve ceza'daki gibi iyi bir insan
olduğuna dair çıkış koyduğumda
isteyereke beslemeyerek Hangimiz
gururunu ayaklar altına almak için yer
altından botlardaki gibi ya da
hangimizi böyle peşinde koştuğumuz bir
şeyi düşünün Arzu etmişiz Hayal etmişiz
başarmışız falan elde ettikten sonra bu
tepkiyi vermeyen var
mış Hangimiz bir dönem bizi hiç
anlamamasına rağmen çok alakasız birine
aşık olmadık ki yani
ki bu ilişki işleri hakikaten ciddi bir
paragraf olsa esas çelişki orada yani
bize benzeyen insanları seviyoruz ama
bizden farklı insanlara aşık
oluyoruz
senden dedi Sıkılmak senden Sıkılmak
olanaksız demişti tanıştığımızda Çünkü
İçimden hep farklı biri çıkıyor
Seninle yaşamak olanaksız dedi Giderken
Çünkü İçimden hep farklı bir çıkıyor
yani işte bu Paradoks bir yandan şöyle
bir şeye de yol açıyor yani
Biz karşı tarafın iyi tarafını arıyoruz
ama kötü tarafından daha çok
etkileniyoruz ya da belki bu yüzden bizi
iyi hissettirmiş insanlara kıyasla
Kötü hissettirmiş İnsanları daha fazla
yer edip hatırlamamız da belki bu yüzden
sadece küfür etmek için olsa bile
ve bu
Dostoyevski daha en sevdiğim şey İşte
insana dair Bu çelişkilerin çok güzel
bir şekilde yazması ifade etmesi
karakterize etmesiyle ve
şeyi biliyordu çok iyi biliyordu
İnsan Denen mucizevi Hatta en yüce
duygularla birlikte adiliğin bir arada
bulunabileceğini iyi biliyordu ve mutlak
iyi ve kötü diye bir ayrımı yoktu
karakterleri bu kadar karikatürize
değildi
O yüzden de zaten herhalde yani raskolik
öğrencisi bir katile dönüşüyor ama yine
de bir katil olmasına rağmen dünyada en
çok sevilen roman kahramanı
yine konuyu başarıyorum diyorum ki
doğru ya yanlışlığa ulaşmaya çalışarak
başardığını düşünüyorum yani
o yorgun gölge teorisi gibi
yani meziyet nedir bilmek için işte kötü
huylara önce Aşina olması gerektiğini
bilincindeydi
bilincindeydi yanlış bir tanım Olabilir
çünkü bir yandan da bu
Kutup dehaların sanatçıların bu kendi
yeraltını iniş mutluluğunu bilinç dışı
bir şekilde ilişkisi olarak takip
ettiğini de düşünüyorum ki keza
psikanesiz kurucusu freud'da diyorduk ki
yani gittiğim Birçok yerde benden daha
önce oraya Başka Bir şairin gittiğini
vardığını gördüm demişti
yine
psikologların psikolog diye bir tanım
yapardı Dostlar olabilir
bu noktada bir alıntı daha paylaşacağım
Çünkü benim bir saatte anlatamayacağım
şeyi çok iyi özetliyorlar batel diye bir
edebiyat kuramcısı var Edebiyat ve
kötülük diye bir kitabı var yaptığı şey
de şu tırnak içinde kötü yazarların
marketi
yazarların dünyasında dolaşıp
yazdıklarıyla yaşam öykülerini
makale tadında bir kitap Çok hoş bence
altını çizdiğim cümleyi şu
sanatçı aslında bir çilekeştir fakat
ters yönde işleyen bu çile İnsanı bütün
nimetlerden el çekmeye değil tam tersine
bütün yasakları Özellikle de iki büyük
yasağı yani şehveti ve ölümü aşmaya
götürür
Bu da sanki şöyle bir şey demek yani
bunu artık biliyoruz değil mi yani
raskolnikov Mesela Bizim içimizdeki
katili öldüren bir katil ve
Tüm bu yazarların ressamların
müzisyenlerin yaptığı şey sağladığı
katarsis arınma müthiş bir şey yani Hem
kendileri için hem başka bir için yani
stoklama bir fayda sağlıyorlar yani işte
bu işte iniş mutluluğunu yaşıyor uçurum
kusursuz
luğuna
aktarıyorlar ve iki tarafta birbirini
iyileştiriyor falan
Tabii ki
Yani ameliyatımızı bir beyin cerrahı
yapıyor ama zihin dünyamızın
şekillendiren insanlar da bunlar
Ben Bu Yüzden antik kahramanları daha
ilgi çekici buluyorum bunu geçiren tdx'e
de söylemiştim yani başarı ve Erdem
hikayelerinden çok sıkılıyorum çünkü
bunlar yani Bu antik Kahramanlar
kendilerini yaşamaktan çekinmeyen
korkmayan buna cesaret gösterebilen
insanlar ve işte raskolik vermiştim yani
adam sağlıklı Yaşasın diye sabah beşte
uyandırıp koşuya çıkarsak
işte dönüşte son Rublesi ile bir
kaybedertmek yerine işte yulaf Gelirsek
ne olur falan diye çünkü
Ya bırak o son parasıyla kirasını
ödemeyi versin zaten yetmeyecek ona da
yetmeyecek Belki o oralar Aklına bir şey
gelecek işte onun yani ve onu yapacak
hani
işte ya da bu kosgöreği var işte
at yarışlarına çok bayılıyor kadın ve
alkol düşük
düşkünü beğenmeyebilirsiniz ben de
istemem arkadaşım olsun istemem yani
sıkıntı bir adam borç isteyecek kız
arkadaşlarıma yürüyecek
mekanikse kavga çıkaracak evin ve
çağırsam kusacak ama yazsın yani
gölgesinde Yaşasın Ne yapıyorsun yazsın
ve okuyorum
gölge teorisi Biraz önce bahsettiğim Ama
bahsetmediğim biraz da bununla alakalı
süre varsa iki dakika anlatayım var
Yani özetle hepimizin sahip olduğu
Gölgeyi sembolik bir anlamla hepimizin
karanlık tarafı olarak gösteriyor ve
diyor ki onu diyor bastırmayın yaşayın
dönüştürün
Tabi biz böyle değiliz yani İnsanlar
genel olarak
bunu bastırır saklamaya çalışır ama o da
der ki yani Başımız ağrıdığında kafanızı
kesmiyorsanız bununla da baş etme
yöntemi bulmanız gerekiyor falan diyor
özetlerin özeti Tabii bunun dışında
tabii kolay bir şey değil insanın kendi
hayatını yemesi Çünkü orada
karşılaşacağı şeyler hiçbir zaman hoşuna
gitmez
çok iyisin sen bir tanesin yavrum benim
falan ama işte o egonun tuzağını düşünün
kendini bulamıyor insan inşa edemiyor
tekrar
işte yok da bununla ilgili diyor ki yani
bunu bastırmayın
aslında bütün hikaye özet olarak şöyle
toplayayım antik Roma'da hep dedikleri
gibi filozofların kendinizi bilmekten
başlıyor insanın kendi yer altına inmesi
yani işte Dostoyevski ve bütün büyük bu
sanatçıların yaptığı şey buydu Ben Bu
Yolu
kendimi önerdiğim için size de
öneriyorum Yani bunu bu yoldan bize
geçebilir Çünkü aslında temelde
bütün her şey kaynağı bu yani Kendimizi
bu keşfetmeden başka birinin sevgide
veremeyiz başka bir şeyle toplumda
bütünleşmek de imkansız
çıkarsa sevgi de öyle bir şey yani
ne var ne verebilirim ne olabilir Ne bir
bakmak yapıyorum
Çünkü çıkışıyla güzel oluyor
özellikle benim anlatacaklarım
diyeceklerim bu kadar dinlediğiniz için
teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]